and we're live
so
anyone who's joining us shortly thank
you for doing so uh firstly hello
everyone and uh welcome to the second
virtual discussion together with the
heroes of stem and science mission
uh heroes of stem as i've mentioned to
you previously in one part earlier final
discussions
is a community of individuals
professionals as well as students from
these ten fields generally and we're
looking to make an impact
within and also outside the the
community and i'd really highly
encourage you to visit the link
um off the group on on the website and
also in the description
lately on the youtube channel
uh we've had a lot of support from
science mission especially so southeast
by thank you for uh for your help sir
the chef
um and the idea we're trying to
build on going from last time is to
continue building mathematic
associations particularly in stems and
different sectors within stems so today
we're joined by dr sean brown
who is a senior lecturer a lecturer at
the university uh hubbard in dundee
and he's over the course of his his
career in science and academia he's a
supervised number of individuals a lot
of students but he's also
seen most of it i think in terms of
academia going from the phd to uh other
students to
the undergrad degrees and all forms of
goods and bad stuff of research
essentially
including i suppose also industrial
collaborations and other forms of uh
international and national collaboration
so i think we'll have lots to hear from
him in a minute about um
exactly what sort of techniques and
methods go into making science career
and a research career
um
so i think we'll just begin with a few
quick words from you a few quick
comments from you sean if you'd like to
add something to your introduction
please
yeah hi um hello to everyone who might
be joining us
um perhaps it might be um
easiest if i sort of gave you my
educational background
um
i'm from glasgow originally hence the
funny accent
so apologies to anyone who can't
understand me um i did my undergraduate
at strathclyde university
i studied biochemistry and pharmacology
um i very much enjoyed the pharmacology
side of things so i pursued that um
side of things for my phd which i did at
university college london
i went once i've completed that that was
2001.
i
stayed at university college um but
moved to a different department
um to begin my first postdoc where i
learned lots of interesting things
and then i moved up to dundee to do my
second postdoc
and then after about two years
in that position i secured electric rp
and that was 2007
and i've been there ever since was
pretty much 10 year anniversary this
year
oh excellent thank you for that strong
it's a great uh background and we know
that much more about your background
your education and your specialization
as well in fact this is this is one of
the reasons we're having this discussion
with you because your technical
specialization is something that's quite
um unique in a way that not not too many
people uh tend to have trained in the
same area but um just opening up to the
to the actual discussion as to why we're
here discussing this all together
um the current stats around stem
professionals and academias that nearly
half of individuals go on to
to pursuing a phd will not have a career
in science or in academia or in fact
even in stems in their future careers
and
considering that only 12.8 percent of
postgrads or phds actually go into also
having a postdoc in places like in the
usa um
it makes you wonder is is there just a
major saturation these days or are we
just looking at very heavy competition
across the board
and of course i'm talking about just
sciences and stems hardcore stems where
the growth rate essentially annually is
1.5 percent
so considering the intake of individuals
who are now taking phd student
scholarships on
even starting post talks um where is the
space to accommodate all these postgrads
where's the possibility that you can
have a stable long-term career in
science assuming that's what you want
and uh based off of this
notion and this concept that there is a
lot more competition there's a lot more
difficulty in securing
fellowships
securing funding around your uh
scientific work even getting
publications out uh what should one's
strategy be when it comes to
approaching a science or research degree
particularly a phd
so uh
shall we begin with the very simple
question of
when you're looking for a phd project
what should you really be focusing on to
begin like should you be focusing more
on the research training aspect the
institute or the facilities available
around the institute sean would you like
to get started on that piece
yeah i mean
i think you have to
view as most things in life holistically
and you have to approach each
potential position on its own merits
obviously um individuals will have their
own interests and i think that's should
be the primary driver um
you know again from my experience i was
supposed it was a long time ago now and
the competition wasn't so much
um
i went into it slightly naively
but primarily i followed my own interest
um
and you know the basis of that i've
shifted field several times but the
basis of that was was iron channel
function and that still is my interest
um so i i think
that should be the primary driver
right obviously an individual wants to
have um prospects and a career
but that could be
you know a minimum of three years down
the line if you see your phd through
which i think
everyone should regardless of how
difficult it is
and it can be extremely difficult again
i've i've been now i nearly quit my phd
after three months oh wow
yeah
so i think everyone should take a little
heart from that that it's very much
about character building
but for your own interests
so
if
i think fundamentally
now my buy for anyone choosing a phd
would be a your interest
but me b make sure the project is well
thought out so i mean it should be
hypothesis driven
it should have very clear aims
and
you should know where you fit into that
um and where the productivity will be
for you
um
because of course
you have your own
interest your self-interest
um but so does the person employing you
so they will be looking at you in terms
of what you can offer
which when you're starting off in phd is
really much
it's largely about potential that they
see
obviously you've done your undergraduate
so again
you should be aiming to excel as as much
as you can
you know
in the theory side of things as well as
any technical skills you can you can
pick up
but you have to convince them that
you'll
bring something
um and you will produce
which is probably why it's extremely
difficult difficult because the pressure
is there from day one
so i think yes interest
um
but it should be a very clear defining
project
that's a really good point
again now you touched on a very
important point of character building
which i
couldn't agree more on um
at some level again from my own
experience with phds when i should have
introduced myself i did my phd in
so-called medical studies specializing
in diabetes and diabetic complications
at the university of exeter and during
my phd i was constantly being told that
you should be viewing phd as a research
training opportunity essentially see it
as an extensive
experience of focused research training
don't view it as a one single project
scenario
and
if i were to throw this question i guess
around this way that
if you are to look at phds more as
research training in character building
should you be so focused on things like
the translational aspect of the project
or whether or not the project really is
i mean you've already said that it needs
to be hypothesis driven
but the nature of hypotheses is that it
may or may not turn out the way you
expect things to turn up
there's always going to be that uh space
that you know your project doesn't
necessarily go
or it isn't viable to the full extent of
the phd
in which case should you be concerned
more with the translation aspect of the
project and the actual core of the
project which at that stage of your
career probably aren't that exposed to
anyway as you've also rightly mentioned
or should you be more concerned about
what sort of techniques and methods are
you picking up how generic are they how
applicable are they across the board on
life sciences
um and the fact that you are learning to
become an independent researcher mostly
so most of anything else
yeah there's a lot in that i think um
when you start your phd
again you're winning with that
into that with the best intentions and i
think if you hit
the scenario of
um
you know your project's not going where
you hope it is now that's primarily
your hope is usually your supervisor
hope as well so there's this like
conflict of interest there
um and i've seen some issues
arise because of that
but i think fundamentally you have to
make
it work in terms of productivity
because the the gold standard still is
having at least one publication
so i think
from hell on high water you have to find
something in your project to get
published
um
so for example when i was doing my phd i
i was very fortunate that my supervisor
was very publication
driven and had very clear
ideas for that
but all of them not all of them were of
interest to me so i had a side project
which i which i was running and i got a
publication out of that
so there are these um
potential
avenues and bear in mind you know
you are training to be a scientist so
you should have those ideas
if you're hitting a brick wall and you
have no ideas then really perhaps you
should be considering if science is
actually for you
that's a fair point that's absolutely
good true um the only thing of course
the point that comes up when it comes to
publications is that um
at least in the informatics which is
probably the only sector currently in
life sciences or in conjugate sort of
combined combined
life sciences is that
this is the only thing that's growing in
it fast enough these days to result in
four to five publications one phd
on average these days a phd with some
level of difficulty might skip one
publication
and um just the level of getting a good
high impact factor journal uh to publish
your work is or the amount that goes
into it these days is that much more
difficult um
most people with papers these days take
up to three to five years to actually be
put together
uh in which case
you are still right that you do need a
publication in order to prove that
you've got the potential to be a
scientist and to actually manage
attendee track position on a later stage
of your career but um besides
publications is anything else you can be
looking into
in a way to de-risk your your time
watching your phd
yeah i think you hit the word
uh perfectly there's a d risk the way i
always um phrase that as you should
always in plan b
very keen on having a pawn b
um certainly
your technical side of things you should
work on that as much as possible
part of being a phd
student is becoming an expert in
something now if
if you're in a lab where the techniques
are very generics of western blots you
know pcr type things that's very
difficult
um because you know you can go into any
lab these days and do that
so again you'd have to
judge that on a case-by-case basis you
know why you're in department it's big
enough for you to kind of you know once
you've made a few friends maybe you'll
have an afternoon on a particular bit of
equipment that you have a particular
interest in
um that's the technical side of things
um
the sort of
pdp as we call it personal development
side of things
is very much encouraged
certainly with
inaudible at the moment so we have
internal funded phds
and
that's part of the graduate school
um it's available on our website we'll
just plug that
while i'm on if anyone's interested
and part of the graduate school ethos is
to
bring
out
additional transferable skills
from phd students
so you have your traditional
science training your heart you attend
conferences as much as possible
scientific conferences but you can
attend lots of all our conferences and
training workshops um to make to improve
your employability essentially
um because you know the matter of fact
is that
as you've said very few people
stay in in academia long term
um and some people want to get out very
quickly but some people are still
enjoying the science they're going to
sort of industry side of things some
people might think well you know
i'll just go and do teaching or
something which is perfectly valid so
you need those um additional skills to
make yourself competitive
in every aspect you want to choose your
future career
that's actually a really good point also
you mentioned that
the person development front
i think when we talk about de-risking
the possibility of a particular project
not necessarily picking up the way you
expect it to maybe not getting the
funding you need or the attention at a
given time because maybe a labs focus
somewhere else um these could be things
like potentially teaching at the same
time or uh spending a little bit more
time dedicating a bit more time to
transfer to building on a transferable
skill could be a really good way of
ultimately risking
a quiet potential in your career so that
could be really interesting going around
this um
you already briefly touched on the idea
of the unique methods versus a more
generic
methodology in most labs these days
trouble of course is that most methods
these days are becoming high throughput
so most labs can now for example do
sequencing which in former times 10 15
years ago wasn't that frequent as well
um the way that's changing is extremely
um
rampant these days in terms of
techniques being
from microarrays to any form of
proteomics you really can mass produce
just about anything in most labs
so
how would you go about
what's your idea of describing a unique
method do you think there's a obscurity
to a certain method or it's
um specialization meaning extremely or
it's application i should say rather
being extremely
uh limited to a certain small number of
individuals is that unique to you or is
it more just the sort of um hardware
that's a hardware that's involved
uh the cost around it that might be
potentially uh the reason why it's
unique
yeah i don't know i don't know the
statistic but apparently you know
there's thousands and hundreds of
thousands of jobs that will be taken by
robots over the next few years but i
think science is ahead of the game on
that one
um
so for example i'm loosely involved with
um
a project done to university as part of
our collaboration um
and it's their new
phenotypic screening center if you have
a look at their website something about
star trek
um you know there's
lots of machines robotic arms it's high
po high throughput screening
um and that might look very attractive
and you know shiny and exciting
but
if you are sitting there and all you
have to do is load a plate in the
machine and press a button that's not
intellectually demanding it's not
technically demanding so you've got to
be very careful about
approaching something like that because
you know if you step out the lab and try
and get a position elsewhere the chances
are not going to have that equipment
and so actually you could be
under skilled
so there is
always said an issue with generic
training like western blots and pcrs
there's something um
important about learning those kind of
basic techniques
the way i approached it was was
something
a little different but i mean again i
was unfortunate i was interested in iron
channels and so the only way to study
that is using electrophysiology
so when i did my phd it was um into an
electrode voltage comp
which is kind of an intermediate step um
to doing a patch clamp electrophysiology
which i currently do on a virtually
daily basis at the moment
and that's very technical
um it's very
fiddly i don't want a better word
um so that is a
specialty now having said that if my
amplifier suddenly blew up i couldn't
sit and build one
so that you know there are limitations
to my technical ability even though i'm
extremely well-versed and perhaps
content so you know i think i started to
learn that in
2001
i'm kind of still doing it
so you know
my approach
the reason for me learning that was was
again self-preservation so when i
haven't done my phd
i wanted to learn that because i knew
the patch clampers would always be in
demand because it's such a specialized
technique
and so it's came to pass and
so my
recent collaboration
is with i started that primarily because
of that particular skill so again i
switched fields completely
and just applied that technique
um
so i think
if someone's starting off they really
have to be careful
about
their technical specialty
and
really
get really master a technique
so if things do break if problems do
arise
then you can sort them because then you
become valued
and
then you're employable
that's a good point in fact i think over
my own uh the space of my own phd as
well as postdoc that was the one
impression i took away from my time
interacting with other academics and
peers that
most people in a team or group come in
with their one
specialized special technique so nearly
everyone does everything else around the
lab but there's the one technique that
you feel you are responsible for that
the inner way you head uh ranging
straight from the maintenance of the
instrument all the way to
troubleshooting setting up new protocols
doing everything in between potentially
helping establish collaborations outside
if you're in group four this particular
technique where the data might be
involved for example um
so then you've got a very important
point there that um
trying to de-risk again is probably the
word um if not just for the hypothesis
the hypothesis of course is very
important the faculty the facilities are
very important but
having that one mastery of a particular
technique can also help you shift from
one field to another as you've done
successfully in the past
and
keep you relevant
in a sense within your scientific career
um
you've already mentioned a little bit
about your specialized technique and and
how it's uh played an important role in
your scientific career so far
but um
let me just me build a little bit more
on how
a unique method if it is extremely
obscure as you've already mentioned also
with this screening center
how can it potentially also be an
advantage to a long-term career in
interest because the
other aspect of course of doing
something very highly specialized and
becoming too valued in a team
potentially being the only person
amongst a few in the world who can do
something is that you might eventually
become a glorified technician
um how do you
essentially go past that phase
yeah
you you anticipated what i was going to
say very well so i think the advantage
of
having such
maybe
having having access to such specialized
equipment is you can perhaps answer
questions that no one else in the world
can
so
that becomes a combination of the
technical side of things and the
resource
so for example um the project that we're
working on we work on male infertility
and so i can actually patch clamp and
record on channels from individual
sperm
and that's obviously extremely difficult
um
but you know theoretically any
electrophysiologist with access to a
willing male um could perhaps plant
sperm however the technique the resource
advantage we have is we work with the
assisted conception unit nine wells
hospital so we actually have access to
patient cells
now that is an extremely rare um
resource there's perhaps only one or two
people in the world who have such a
regular access to patients
so you have to combine the technical
side of things as well with the resource
side of things as well as the
intellectual side of things
you know so you become a technical
expert but you also become an expert in
your field and so you become known for
that and so people are more willing to
to collaborate
um to give you an extended example of
that we're looking to obviously continue
our research when we're
trying to collaborate with it with
individuals in america
the reason we focused on
certain individuals is because of their
technical
expertise and because of the advanced
technology they can only they can answer
um particular questions
so you know
the downside is
that you
um
might become a glorified technician
potentially but the flip side is that
you could become an international expert
so you know it's it's an extreme
um double-sided coin i think the the
disadvantage for someone who's junior
doing a phd
is you know
they're probably going to be expected to
move on so you're really going to have
to hit on something pretty impressive
very quickly that you can a get your phd
but be then probably be given bridge
money to see write a grant that would
keep you there because because i said
the problem is if you if you're
you have access to unique technical
resources
um that's fine when you're doing your
phd and you'll get your phd which is
great but if you have to move to another
lab then you know you might be
restricted
to know the labs worst case scenario or
maybe one or two
um
you have to kind of think of it in the
long term which is which is why the
fundamentals technical skills
should be taught
um
alongside the advanced chemicals
that's a really good point in fact
that's true not just for life sciences
but generally in all standards that
there are some fundamental techniques
that are just recognized across the
board as being extremely important as a
basic survival kit so to speak and then
you build on them um going from them to
specializing in one or the other format
but
also another important point that you
made is uh something maybe for students
to watch out for is the completion or
the
complete packaging of a given hypothesis
and the way you might be able to execute
your hypothesis testing and
investigation in that will you have
access to clinical samples will you have
access to in vivo experimentation
possibilities um animal models of all
forms or not
i know certain countries are very
restricted when it comes to animal uh
experimentation some countries aren't so
so restricted
and um to what extent is communication
possible within the group uh technical
technical expertise of course being also
an extremely important part of this
package would you suggest that this is
more or less
the case that when you enter
a phd you should be looking out for the
full package in a way uh as to where
potentially your supervisor stands and
how likely your project is to have a
complete transferable i shouldn't say
transferable more translational aspect
to it
you know
translational projects and my experience
are quite limited in terms of you know
if
you're not really going to be going
going in as a phd student and and having
access full access to something which is
you know going to be suddenly
translational on three translational in
three years time you know you'll fit you
you'll fit somewhere in a project maybe
um
so i i think
personally i would advise people if they
have the opportunity
to
go for a phd that has translational
aspects to it in terms of
you do the basic science
but actually you're part of a team that
involves
a medic perhaps
and they're saying very much they're
bringing that side of side in i mean
part of our
team
involves obviously the basic scientists
like myself
but we have a couple of consultants um
who are interested in the research
side of things that work in the assisted
conception unit you know so they give
absolutely invaluable
um
medical and clinical insight as well as
obviously
allowing us access to the patients that
examples
exactly great great i fully agree with
you i think you you can't expect to have
a translational project that you haven't
come up with for yourself uh to be
handed to you as a phd student that's
that's really wishful thinking but at
some level i guess you do need the blue
sky uh thinking in the broader version
of where the project might go in order
to commit to it because like you've said
a phd is an extremely um
uh consuming uh form of uh undertaking
and you wouldn't want to sign off three
to five years of your life unless you
know it's gonna go somewhere
specifically
uh in your favor
in which case i guess as long as as long
as you're part of a team potentially
that has a bigger picture in mind i
think it really makes it worth the while
so other than um the facility the
faculty
and the expertise just knowing whether
whether you're a part of a bigger puzzle
or if you're just uh
working in isolation somewhere i guess
is the other
potential factor to look into
yourself
in my experience as i said i went
slightly naive not slightly very naively
um
and i
again i'm giving that advice having made
the mistake of
my phd wasn't focused it would
i had some ideas i had some aims as much
but didn't have hypothesis it was kind
of much
it's more sort of drug screening type
phd and it was
it was pretty boring to be honest and
that's why i started my side project
because i went into phd because i
enjoyed the intellectual reward for my
undergraduate
and the phd didn't quite
fit that um
so that was that was a bit of a struggle
so you know that's one of the reasons
that i
actually
jumped field immediately
after my phd so i was working on
i suppose
it was basically a
purine field so i was working on p2x
receptors and drugs that acted on atp
sensitive channels
and then i went
to do my first post talk um
on um
g protein gated potassium channels
still iron channels i still had that
interest
um but my primary driver for that was to
learn patch clamping because it was it
was a patch clamp project
now
so i
i was very fortunate actually to have
an offer from cambridge university as
well as university college london
at that point to do a postdoc and
i don't know if this is a sensible idea
or not but i i turned down cambridge
because
um the project
was still in the p2
x field um
so that was kind of my very original
interest from my undergraduate through
my phd
but but somehow the project itself it
didn't really excite me it was on red
blood cells
i don't know why it just didn't really
excite me
um but the one at ucl i was also
learning patch comping
i was switching field which actually
kind of got me excited again
and i learned a ridiculous number of
techniques you know i
i learned
pcr and i went like cell culture
um
one day i picked up i had to pick up a
protocol and basically purify protein
kinase from rat brain having never done
it before
so you know i was completely autonomous
um to the extent that my supervisor left
halfway through the project to get
another job so it was entirely up to me
to drive that project
which again i found very exciting
i made the mistake though subsequently
um
of when i came to dundee the the project
was i i brought a lot to that project
because of the skills i had learned in
london but i got nothing back
so
i was i was really bored
really bored and
the project was going nowhere
i could see it was going nowhere at
least i had my head switched on that
much at that point in time so i knew i
had to
kind of
salvage something of a career at that
time because it really was all or
nothing at that point
and so i i got
interested in
um how to teach
people techniques that came into the lab
so you know prospective phd students
um
that's one of the perhaps things they
need to check is is the training that
we're going to get and who's going to do
the training because you might never see
your supervisor
that that's a that's a reality for some
people
um so i was very much interested in
improving the the the training for
students who come into the log because
it's generally done on a sort of ad hoc
basis
and so i started my postgraduate
certificate in teaching in higher
education
and then the job at alberta came up and
i know abertay is historically
um
a teaching university
so
i kind of
thought well i'm going to follow the
teaching route and put
the research wrote to one side and i
essentially
famous last words never say never i said
i'd never patch clamp again
um that was in 2007.
um
so
you've done about a million since
yeah yeah
fortunately
maybe unfortunately as well i i started
doing it again about three years ago and
again i switched fields so you know i
from ucl i did the potassium chain of
the channel things at dundee i did sort
of um epithelial sodium channels
um and then i kind of
hung up my pet if you like for a few
years and then now i am certainly
reproductive biology field and that has
just
you know
got me excited again
you know we've got some really um great
papers out
um we've got the mrc grant which is
coming to name or we're applying
um for more funding soon i've just
written a big review the biggest thing
and hopefully the best thing i've ever
written
so you know there are multiple routes
that people should realize that are
available i think one thing that people
kind of assume that is
um you know
i must
do my phd i must get my postdoc and
watch write my first grant and let's get
my first grant and that's me becoming a
pi and you know all the pressures and
everything that go along with that
actually you can you can take a little
bit of the breath and realize that
there's a lot of universities there's a
lot of teachers in universities and
colleges
that don't have money they don't have
research they still enjoy the science
um so if you
if you really do enjoy the science then
perhaps you should stick with it a
little bit longer because
i did and it kind of worked out for me
so far
[Music]
uh one of the points that i also noticed
in in what you were describing as
switching fields
back on myself
i was made to understand through a lot
of clinical scientists uh that
you can't get too attached to a field
because you're not actually uh
specializing with mythology
whether you like it or not you're a
molecular biologist or a cell biologist
or geneticist and that's really where i
eventually i think i'm sure this is
something you'd agree with as well
that's when you realize that this is
what my strength is this is what my
actual specialization is uh which is
going to enable me to move between
different fields and sectors potentially
through different pathologies i've for
example my own case gone from working on
gmb3 and hypertension with you many
years ago back in aberdeen to
diabetes and diabetic complications for
my phd and
pre-diabetes during my my first post
talk and now very soon i'll be working
on breast cancer uh which you think is
completely different but all of it has
very similar
uh technical and sort of um
cellular level uh undertones so to speak
so i think that's it's extremely
important what you mentioned that you've
got to be able to um
right out the waves essentially and
think in terms of what can take the back
burner today um or can take the
forefront for a little while now even if
it's not exactly what you expected
because the career in research and
academia is a mixture of teaching of
guiding projects potentially being
supervisor to small groups or
even just master students or postgrads
or other phds and uh also obviously the
science the actual uh glorious sounding
ground writing and paper writing and
review writing and everything else in
between
but excellent points thank you that
actually does give a very good summary i
think overall of what we're trying to
achieve um the other two factors that
i'd really like to try and build on a
little bit is um
firstly moving labs so after your first
post talk did you find that you wanted
to continue on with the post talk so
this is the transition that i think a
lot of scientists and i realize we
haven't had a chance to discuss this in
uh
in advance but uh
do you think a lot of postdocs struggle
to understand when to draw the line with
being a postdoc and really take that
leap and say okay maybe i go down the
lectureship route or i take down the the
pi route or i forget about academia for
the moment to get into industry with the
possibility of switching back because
there's so much more crosstalk between
industry and academia these days anyway
um
please your comments let me turn back
your mic
yeah
i think fundamentally
a tip for life is be flexible i don't
just mean touch your toes you know
that's useful as well
everyone should do a bit of yoga now
again
um
you know you've got uh
you've got to feed yourself and your
family
um
so don't
put pride in the way i think
particularly big universities
and i one of my friends who i went to
university suffered from this
you know
she had i think she had two two grants
yet she was
made to feel undervalued
which is just insane to the extent that
she left
she had a research group and she just
left
because she was made to feel so
undervalued
which i think is a horrendous thing i
think there's this um
it's a very strange attitude um
for some people in science that
perhaps it drives us all that you know
you somehow have to you know be the next
einstein and if you're not bringing in
millions of pounds that's not good
enough
well actually you know
perhaps one of the best things to do is
if you're good at it is teach someone
so
there are very few individuals who have
enough money
to have no teaching
and the chances are
they don't want to do any teaching
and the chances are they'd be rubbish at
teaching
now that's fine if you want to run a
research institute and we absolutely
need people like that
but of course
every single person who's wanting to do
a phd is probably been taught by someone
who's very good at some point in time
so they should take you that's something
they might want to consider so you
should you should be flexible
if you have an opportunity to work in
industry
take it because it's another
string to your goal
um it's something i've never done um
i've never had the opportunity
and the opportunity arose
at certain point in time i
probably would have taken it
but in terms of
when you draw the line again that's very
personal
i was fortunate in that i seen the line
coming
but
was able to do something about it
um
again it's entirely personal
if anyone asked me should i do a phd i
would never discourage them
i think
it's a personal development
thing and in the grand scheme of things
it's only three years
um
i would never then discourage anyone
doing a postdoc
but at that point you've got to really
consider
do you want to be a scientist can you
put up with the long hours can you put
up with the
different
pressures
can you put up with the sacrifices that
you inevitably have to make the
compromises that you have to make now
sure every career has that
but i think science has
some
unique ones and ones that some people
find difficult to understand
um
you know if we've got marking deadlines
they have to be done so you have to work
weekends you have to work in the
evenings
um
the review i mentioned that i've written
i've i wrote it in the evenings when i
when i came in
so i was doing my experiments during the
day and
i take a break and go to the gym but
then in the evening i come back in and
then start writing again
now
no one's making me do that that's part
of how i'm driven
but some people
will have to do that even though they
don't want to if if they stay in science
so you've really got to be aware of what
it involves but part of that is a
learning process which happens during
your phd you know you
observe and see how other people are
succeeding or not
and you kind of begin to form your own
opinions and
desire to continue further i think
that's a good point in fact this is i
think where it comes back to what my uh
phd supervisor would also say that treat
your phd like a trailer for your career
in science and research uh
think take it as days to attest to uh of
sorts that you know is this the way
you'd like to live for the rest of your
life this kind of career you can wake up
to and be excited about every day
and
also the points you made about um
i think just the hierarchy and the
conditioning that goes into most
individuals of course you're right that
most people with a phd are taught by
somebody who's
particularly specialize in the technique
particularly good at something at a
certain given time but i think the
conditioning typically for most phds is
that your success if you remain in
academia and if you remain in science so
this is why a lot of people cling on to
the post docs even when it's time to let
go potentially
whereas teaching is the next best thing
in industries when you don't do well
enough in science apparently uh even if
the life is going to be different and
you're right ultimately pressure is the
same across any board whichever query
you can take what seems like the
simplest career possible anywhere else
stems or elsewhere
this pressure is everywhere depends on
how passionate you are about something
or how driven you are about something or
how important something is to you
but i think conditioning potentially
plays an extremely important role in the
way we perceive occurring in science and
i think what i'm picking up from
our discussion so far primarily is that
it is about interesting especially
something like sciences and research
career i guess
um so much fit is about your passion and
what your your heart is willing to go
after um so you can't really
i guess you can't really put too much
protocol on it but having said that um
in terms of techniques and in terms of
an ongoing personal development as well
as technical development would you say
that it's safer to not take a steady
state route in science and in stems when
you're doing a research degree or even
looking at a long-term research career
would it be fair to say that it's
worthwhile constantly taking on yourself
and going in for continuity education to
keep adding either
certifications or courses or techniques
to your
to your timeline uh even if you're
you're hitting all the so-called
milestones when it comes to grants when
it comes to reviews and vapes etc
yeah i mean
well
it depends which stage you're at you
know if you if you're hitting your
grants and your papers when you're a
postdoc and then a lecture i think
you're okay you know you should always
want to
upskill i guess
um
when you're a phd student
i think you should
take you should be strategic about it
again i think you should take ones which
you think will have the potential
biggest benefit
there might be a few random ones you
might want to try just to see what
happens and then you know
who knows what happens
but i think you you've got to be smart
with your time
um
so you think you should be strategic
about it but but definitely
you know
take advantage of what's available
okay
i think we'll just round up because this
has
been really really insightful i think
the whole discussion so far um the one
final comment i'd like from you is um
from perspective of you going back to
your
pre-phd days let's say
uh based off of our discussion so far if
you had to approach your phd all over
again how would you go about it now
knowing what you just discussed
in terms of specialized versus uh highly
uh general techniques how would you um
maybe would you change something would
you do anything differently
well that's going to be a careful one
because the benefit of hindsight i think
where i am
i've been extremely extremely fortunate
because i have taken an unconventional
route to get to where i am
now part of that is
i've always been reasonably good at
sporting an opportunity
but i think if i was
giving myself advice
um
you know when i was you're you're that
period of choosing phds
i think i i would really research into
it more
and what i actually involved and
you know was it fully funded and who was
funding it etc
there's other things like you know that
the politics within the department it
wasn't great either the department i was
in and
again people can suffer because of that
and i think
i think i can stay clear of it mostly
but
you know not truly
um
but that's difficult to assess um
because you know when you go for an
interview you can't really start
grilling people in a department but how
everybody gets on
but i think to do your research
that's what you're gearing yourself up
for our life also you might as well
start
researching what's the best
for you
that's actually i think those are the
best words to conclude uh you're very
right i think if you want a career
there's there's two things that i think
i want to see is you know people are
doing
considering doing
uh phds
because it's
hopefully what's what's interesting
but i think they should also be aware
that they have the opportunity
to
observe something and record something
that no other person in history has ever
done
and i think that's that's extremely
important i think that should
motivate a lot of people so no matter
what your boss says no matter what the
leader in the field says they have no
right to tell you that you're wrong
i think you should do the experiment
and then you know go on the data i think
that
that's pretty pretty fundamental
you know the other final thing i think i
want to say is
if you're working in a field and it
doesn't excite you it doesn't really
stimulate you
then it's probably not for you
because you the sacrifices that you make
will be driven by that interest and
excitement
that's a great point thank you so much
for those great insights from nanda for
your time especially i'm sure people
will benefit a great deal from this and
uh
you would share of course the the web
link to uh
the screening uh
webpage you mentioned earlier at nine
wells uh we'll have that also in the
description so you can look through and
maybe even reach out to you if necessary
but thank you so much for your time and
all the
wonderful answers and we'll catch you
again soon thank you all right thank you
kirti
bye
you